eben sucks president mr. president the
Constitutional Court has decided not to
bang the NPD you won't against striving
for any bid to ban the party do you now
feel vindicated you should have fun
Longfellow oven for many observers the
course of the court proceedings itself
the Federal Constitutional Court's
deliberations hinted at the verdict that
was announced today while we agree with
the assessment of the upper chamber of
parliament with that the NPD is
certainly an anti constitutional party a
party with anti-constitutional aims in
contrast to the upper chamber we from
the lower parliamentary chamber did not
feel a ban was politically necessary nor
did we created such a proposal with
having especially good chances of
success in this respect I feel my
assessment has been reaffirmed by
today's verdict in minor and jetsam Bush
daddy he daughter do makati mojo and
democracy and need not fear that's right
wing extremists NPD z mu Z Antonin we
have to like it seriously just as I
recommend closely following everything
that happens in our society not least
attempts to influence public opinion we
have to take it especially seriously if
it threatens to cross boundaries set by
our Constitution or even crosses them
these boundaries regard principles of
democracy and human rights here the
Federal Constitutional Court has
determined with unmistakable clarity
that this line has certainly been
crossed by the NPD oily homeless first
and if catfish does by the linnean from
the NPD guns Zika uber taagan Verdun
habibs of life but at the same time it
has reminded us that banning an
organization within the framework of a
liberal Constitution should only take
place if there's a truly serious danger
of it achieving its anti-constitutional
aims Zawya for thousands finally here
tila gift danke positon tank of this
interview